Perhaps the most important thing to know
about crime is that it doesn’t happen at
random. Crime is heavily concentrated in several
different ways. We know that a small number of
offenders are responsible for a big chunk of
all crime. We know that unfortunately a small
number of people are at higher risk of being
victims of crime over and over again. And we
also know that crime is heavily concentrated in
a small number of places. So the reason we put
crime on maps is to help us understand where
different types of crime happen most often.
Take this map of homicides in the city of
Medellin in Columbia. We can see straightaway that
homicides aren’t evenly distributed throughout
the city – a big proportion of all the homicides
happen in a small number of places. There are
more homicides in the city centre and very few
in some outlying districts. If we wanted to set
up a project to prevent homicides in Medellin,
or we wanted to know where it would be
best to build a new trauma hospital,
the information on this map could be very useful.
Researchers have done lots of work to find out
exactly how concentrated crime is in particular
places. Generally, this has found that about half
of crime happens on about five percent of streets,
with violent crimes tending to be slightly more
concentrated than property crimes. That also means
that most places experience either very little
crime or no crime at all. This rule – that most
crime happens in a small minority of places
– is known as the law of crime concentration.
The early research on this topic was
mostly done in the United States,
with researchers finding that half of crime in
Seattle happened on five percent of streets,
while in Cincinnati half of crime
happened on six percent of streets.
More recent research has found similar
results for other countries. For example
half of violence in Oslo in Norway
happens in six percent of small areas,
while in Kaduna in Nigeria half of burglaries
happen at about eight percent of addresses.
In fact, this heavy concentration of
crime in a small number of places has
been found for every type of crime in every
country that researchers have studied.
It’s important to note when we’re
talking about crime concentration
that crime is primarily concentrated at
small places such as individual addresses
or streets. Even in an area that might be
described as a high crime neighbourhood,
we will typically find that most crime happens
at a few addresses or on a few streets,
with the rest of the neighbourhood having
quite low levels of crime. That is why in
this course, we will primarily be looking
at concentrations of crime at micro places,
such as addresses and streets, rather than
analysing crime at a neighbourhood level.
All this means that if we want to understand
crime, or to try to stop it, then it’s really
important to know where crime happens. And
that’s why it’s useful to put crime on maps.
To summarise:
Crime doesn’t happen at random – it is
concentrated in several different ways.
Most crime happens in a small number of high-crime
places, while most places have no crime at all.
The law of crime concentration applies to
different types of crime in
many different countries.